[Music]
hello everyone its Alisa Malone this is
another episode of San Diego indie movie
Guide and stay tuned to the end because
I'm going to be giving you my five films
that I'm most looking forward to seeing
at South by Southwest which starts this
Friday
let's first let's start with personal
shopper now this is a film that I saw it
can last year it's a ghost story but at
the premiere that I went to the boos
came at the end of the movie and I was
really shocked by that I mean it happens
and can all the time but I thought it
was a brilliant film a ghost story and a
haunted movie unlike any that I've seen
before it stars Christmas to it as a
personal shopper who's living in Paris
she's dressing this really famous woman
but she's actually waiting for the
moment she'll get to connect with her
brother who has passed away and she
wants to connect with him through the
other side listen really spooky scenes
in here but it's definitely a metaphor
for the haunting of her life
the grief itself and Kristen is amazing
she's been almost every scene she holds
the screen she is mesmerizing to watch
because it defies these genre
conventions of every other haunted movie
you've seen before you really don't know
what to expect so I found it tense and
thrilling and I loved the fact that it
leaves a lot of things open-ended and
everyone's going to have a different
take
through the present do you think Lewis
is here I don't know I go to sit down
with Kristen Stewart and director
Olivier Assayas to talk about personal
shopper have a look when you're a writer
or filmmaker you try to get in touch
with what makes individuals individuals
and ultimately what makes them realize
the complexity you know and and so and
the complexity has to do with our
relationship would think that that are
visible and we have understandable to to
us so I think is pretty universal why
would they do the store they were
telling the way that he works with
everyone that he works with actors and
crew and just creative partners in
general is that you find you know he's
the ignition for a thought process and
ultimately he absolutely wants those
those thought processes processes to
remain individual and absolutely owned
by you and then you kind of push those
all together and in the end that's what
the film is okay from ghosts to
cannibals and I have another audience
story about this one as well
raw is a film that I saw at Toronto last
year and it made the headlines because
some people fainted in the screening
that I was at now there's been stories
about it being because of the gore and
grisly stuff happening on-screen but I
have a theory that it's probably more to
do with the amount of alcohol that
people were drinking that night I don't
know I've a weak stomach and I found it
fine
it's a French Belgian film directed by
Julia do Cano who is a brilliant first
time female director badass and she
definitely shows some cool style with
this it's about a young girl who goes to
study to be a vet she's a vegetarian but
then a horrible hazing ritual gives her
the taste for meat and then eventually
human meat
[Music]
really this is all that's another
metaphor for growing up for coming into
your own power for learning who you
really are and also for the sexual
awakening that can happen during the
college years I highly recommend you
watch raw it's not Antichrist don't
worry about that it won't make you think
there will be moments when you won't
want to look at the screen but the gore
is justified in there's so much meat for
you to bite into onto another taboo
subject now with the documentary the
last laugh which focuses on the kinds of
jokes you can make about horrible events
like the Holocaust this is a fascinating
topic it's all about whether you should
be allowed to joke about these very dark
subjects where the humor can actually be
healing where there can be laughter for
revenge or if there's some subjects that
you should just not touch an interesting
topic and very well put together so look
out for the documentary the last laugh
it is available right now in select
theaters expanding to more theaters this
Friday
you cannot blink in the shadows I enjoy
life because it's so imagine that I will
survive and have three gradualism
I mean that's my revenge and in just a
few days I'm heading to Austin for the
South by Southwest Film Festival this
festival is so much fun not only do you
get the cool vibe of being in Austin
with the taco and the margaritas and the
people and everything that happens there
but also the films that play as South by
Southwest are great because you get the
festival favorites movies that are
played at Sundance before then you get
the kind of the bigger films these genre
films there's all these great stumps as
well so I'm so looking forward to being
amongst the madness and here are the
five films I'm most looking forward to
seeing let's start with baby driver
directed and written by Edgar Wright
it's having its premiere at the South by
Southwest Film Festival and this is more
of an action thriller than one of his
comedies it's about a young getaway
driver who falls for a waitress who
works at a diner filled with 70s film
references and a rockin soundtrack song
to song is directed by Terrence Malick
and I am a sucker for a Malick film this
is set against the music scene at Austin
so it's perfect to play during South by
Southwest but I just love going in and
experiencing his films to me they're
more like art pieces than straight
narrative movies
small-town crime has a fantastic cast
including John Hawkes who plays an
ex-cop she finds the body of a young
woman and becomes determined to track
down her killer also stars Octavia
Spencer and the Coen looks like
Tarantino meets the colon brothers dark
gritty and funny totally my jam the
disaster artist is one of the works in
progress screenings that's happening at
South by Southwest directed by James
Franco and this tells the true story
behind one of the worst films of all
time called the room I love that movie I
have a soft spot for it you tearing me
apart Lisa so I can't wait to see what
James Franco has cooked up and last but
not least when it all is playing at
South by Southwest and this is directed
by Joe Swanberg this does Jake Johnson
who is once again teaming up with Joe
Swanberg and I love Jake I think he's
hilarious
he plays a small-time gambler
discovers a bunch of money ends up
spending it all and then has to try to
win at that and there are so many other
great films playing at South by
Southwest so make sure you watch the
show next week because I'll be coming
from Austin and I'll give you a list of
everything that I've seen everything you
should be looking out for but this week
don't forget to see in cinemas personal
shopper Raw or the last laugh I'm Elise
Malone I'll see you soon
[Music]